bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 5 février
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici quelques-uns des titres
qui seront développés au cours de la
prochaine demi heure la préfecture des
yvelines lance la campagne
gouvernementale contre la radicalisation
religieuse et annonce une centaine de
signalisation dans ce département
particulièrement touché par le phénomène
quarante sept personnes ont perdu la vie
en 2014 sur les routes des yvelines
prévention répression vont se poursuivre
cette année et notamment envers les
motards projet de loi santé mais aussi
l'absence de revalorisations tarifaires
figurent parmi les griefs des médecins
qui multiplient les grèves depuis
décembre nous en parlerons en plateau
avec la bernadette en bon vice
présidente du syndicat national des
jeunes médecins généralistes
la ville de montigny le bretonneux vient
d'organiser mercredi après midi une
cérémonie commémorative en hommage à cet
aviateur du squadrons 622 qui dépendait
de la royal air force sept soldats morts
le 8 juin 40 1944 sur le territoire de
la commune dans le crash de leur avion
abattu par l'armée allemande la famille
de l'un d'entre eux néo zélandais
étaient présentes neveu petit neveu est
assisté à cette cérémonie du souvenir
une plaque commémorative vous l'avez vue
a été dévoilée par le maire michel
laugier on en vient aux annonces du
préfet des yvelines concernant la lutte
contre la radicalisation le djihadisme
erard corbin de mangoux a lancé la
campagne gouvernementale les détails
avec michael et me d'euros et william
peel
les yvelines sont particulièrement
touchés par le djihadisme zone
d'attention pour les forces de l'ordre
saint quentin en yvelines et la vallée
la scène au total une centaine de
signalements ont été enregistrés depuis
mai 2014 dans le département les
individus auraient en moyenne entre 15
et 30 ans le phénomène concernerait
aussi bien les garçons que les filles on
va pas donner de chiffres parce que ça
n'a pas d'importance mais les yvelines
comme tout départements urbains et de la
région ile-de-france sont naturellement
touché dans tout son espace par cette
situation et et quand je vous disais
sans signalement il se répartit sur
toutes les rues urbaines pour lutter
contre le djihadisme dans les yvelines
le département s'associe à la campagne
nationale contre le terrorisme un numéro
vert a été mis en place une brochure
explicative sur les signaux de
radicalisation est également
téléchargeable sur le site internet de
la préfecture objectif prévenir la
radicalisation et offrir une assistance
aux familles dans la difficulté ce sont
des indices concordants qui font que on
va on va essayer de le constater cette
radicalité c'est décider s'ils ne savent
alors bien sûr les tenues vestimentaires
mais pas seulement c'est peut être aussi
le fait de de ne plus regarder la
télévision de ne plus écouter de la
musique de d'être très forte sur les
réseaux sociaux sur des sites très très
spécifiques ça peut être aussi tu
abandonné le sport ça peut tout leur
sens encore une fois de deux dindes
indices qui permettent de dire il se
passe quelque chose une fois le
signalement effectué des structures
nationales et départementales s'occupe
des individus considérés comme radicaux
au cas par cas nous avons mis en place
comme je pense dans l'ensemble des
départements concernés
d'avoir une cellule de suivi extrêmement
restreinte où tous les cas sont évoqués
et une s'il d'évaluation nationale avec
l'ensemble des partenaires où nous
pouvons la essayer de trouver quel est
l'organisme
l'institution l'association qui est le
mieux à même de prendre en compte la
situation une fois que nous aurons pu
l'évaluer savoir si c'était un vrai
cadre d'utilisation ou bien simplement
un moment difficile d'un adolescent le
djihadisme dans les yvelines fait cette
semaine les gros titres de l'actualité
moussa coulibaly l'agresseur présumé de
trois policiers à nice mardi dernier
habitait le quartier du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie
le préfet des yvelines a également
dévoilé ce mercredi les chiffres de la
sécurité routière sur l'année 2014 le
nombre de morts sur les routes du
département est stable par rapport à
2013 un reportage de william l
les chiffres viennent de tomber 47
personnes ont perdu la vie l'année
dernière sur les routes du département
autant qu'en 2013 le nombre d'accidents
est également stable avec 946 accrochage
contre 947 l'année dernière dans le
rétroviseur de la police ebe noise les
deux roues 25 % des accidents mortels
daisy ville concernent des motards il
faut qu'on continue à travailler qu'à
motards pour qu'il respecte mieux les
limitations de vitesse et quand de la
route je reste persuadé que le
comportement doit être mieux mieux
calibrée et jeu et pour ma part je
continuerai à demander à ce que les
remontées de file trop rapide soit soit
verbalisé par les forces de police parce
que je trouve que ça donne un
comportement beaucoup trop libertaire et
ça donne une route dangereuse un
sentiment de nombre de libertés selon
pour réduire le nombre de morts sur les
routes du département les forces de
l'ordre veulent augmenter les contrôles
de vitesse avec des radars mobiles dans
les secteurs urbains des tests
salivaires pour lutter contre la prise
de stupéfiants sur la route sont
également développées en 2015 une très
très forte hausse d'élite délits
routiers nous avons constaté plus + 40 %
de délits routiers l'année dernière ce
qui est énorme nous avons plus 20% de
délit de grande vitesse dont plus de 40%
donc de délits d'alcoolémie délictuel et
y compris presque plus de 50% de
conduite sous stupéfiants toutes les
semaines 1 je constate des grands excès
de vitesse côté la semaine dernière
c'était 160 km heure au milieu d'un
village limitée à 50 km heure mais si
quelqu'un traverse il ne peut pas
s'arrêter et s'ils essayent d'éviter la
personne le motard va tomber c'est clair
donc là c'est vraiment sont pas des
comportements citoyens mais c'est là
aussi qu'il faut qu'il nous faut
intervenir cette année cinq personnes
ont déjà perdu la vie sur les routes du
département dans deux accidents mortels
en zone rurale on est aussi dans les
intéressés viven association prévention
routière
l'entretien de ce journal à présent avec
bernadette ans vont bien venu sur ce
plateau vous êtes vice présidente des
internes du syndicat national des jeunes
médecins généralistes pour maintenir la
pression sur la ministre de la santé
marisol touraine les médecins
généralistes qui était à nouveau invités
à fermer les portes de leur cabinet ce 5
février vous avait relayé donc cet appel
ce n'est pas la première fois en
décembre dernier déjà la contestation
était forte pourquoi aujourd'hui
renouveler l'action parce que la
précédente mobilisation n'aura
finalement servi à rien il y avait eu
déjà des actions en effet 1 en novembre
2014 et puis le 6 janvier 2015 on a
recommencé à mobiliser les syndicalistes
parce que les négociations n'avançaient
pas et qu'on avait l'impression que
notre revendications n'étaient pas
entendues de la part du gouvernement
parmi les différentes revendications on
va reparler un petit peu il ya le nom à
la généralisation du tiers-payant la
consultation à 25 euros alors déjà tout
d'abord sur la généralisation du tiers
payant
pourquoi ce nom alors en fait c'est pas
un non catégorique c'est surtout un nom
la surcharge de travail que ça va
engendrer notamment pour les
généralistes qui sont déjà accablé d'une
lourdeur administrative énorme et qui
n'ont malheureusement pas d'auxiliaires
médicaux actuellement donc c'est pour
éviter cette surcharge administrative
après on n'est pas contre la génération
du tiers payant au contraire ça peut
apporter un bénéfice et un à un gain
faux patient seulement on risque aussi à
ce moment là de ne pas être payé les
généralistes et donc on aimerait que la
sécu pour ça il faudrait que la sécurité
sociale en fait prennent en charge la
part de la mutuelle et c'est à dire
qu'elles garantissent à elles mêmes la
deux tiers payant généralisé et que à ce
moment là les généralistes à payer
normalement et que ce soit à l'aspect
social qui se charge de faire le lien
avec les mutuelles ce que 650 mutuel
c'est un peu psy pour un généraliste de
pouvoir tout recenser et de récupérer
tous les tous les fonds et pourrait
abaisser le niveau qui était la tâche
administratif du médecin ensuite et
aussi cette consultation à 25 euros la
place des 23 actuellement oui à 25 alors
en fait c'est pour une uniformisation
par rapport aux autres spécialités
depuis quelques années à la médecine
générale est considérée comme une
spécialité à part entière depuis qu'elle
est passée comme spécialité à les
allocations nationales
seulement elle à la majoration du coût
de la consultation qui a été fait pour
les spécialistes n'a pas été appliquée
pour les généralistes se trouve avec 23
euros pour la consultation donc ce qu'on
aimerait c'est une revalorisation du
statut de généraliste en tant que
spécialiste reconnu à part entière et
donc avec une consultation à 25 euros
éventuellement la mise en place d'une
consultation à 28 euros quand il ya un
parcours coordonné avec un spécialiste
parce que souvent dans les coordinations
spécialistes c'est souvent le médecin
traitant qui fait le courrier qu'ils
organiseraient transmission
d'informations et à ce moment-là ça
mériterait une valorisation par rapport
à l'acte donc tiers payant et cette
consultation 25 euros ce sont les deux
revendications fortes notamment qui sont
portés mais ce ne sont pas les seuls
aujourd'hui la ministre de la santé a
répondu un petit peu favorablement est
ce qu'il ya des avancées tout de même
malgré tout dans la discussion alors par
rapport à la consultation à 25 euros ils
ont dit que le gouvernement a annoncé
qu'il ne ferait pas de d'avancé dans ce
sens là par rapport par rapport à
consultation avant les élections
professionnelles qui auront lieu à la
fin de l'année donc là dessus ils sont
un petit peu gelé et par rapport au
tiers payant généralisé ils sont
vraiment intraitable parce que c'est
leur point fort de la loi santé 2015 et
donc ils veulent absolument par m 7
cette piste en question
après peut-être que par les groupes de
travail qui sont en train d'être mis en
place et qui donneront leur rapport mi
février il y aura des aménagements qui
pourront être possible pour éveiller
pour éliminer une surcharge de travail
et repartant donc le bras de fer va se
poursuivre vous représentez syndicat des
jeunes médecins est ce qu'il ya des
revendications spécifiques aussi autour
de cette réforme santé de cette loi
santé qui est en préparation qui sont
portées par votre sentiment oui ce qu'on
aimerait aussi c'est une revalorisation
du statut de l'inter norme nc général et
une voix une revalorisation de la
formation pendant l'internât et puis
ensuite la formation continue
professionnelle
avec notamment plus de moyens pour
l'enseignement pour la recherche est
aujourd'hui la médecine générale est
officielle et à part entière mais la
recherche clinique est un peu le parent
pauvre par rapport aux autres
spécialités avec peu de dotation
financière dans ce sens là et et le
statut des internes est vraiment
précaire avec des délégations qui
avaient été faites par la commission
européenne sur le temps de travail les
internes qui ont pas été du tout reprise
par le gouvernement et qu'aucune avancée
n'ait été fait dans ce sens là et puis
par rapport à la formation continue
parce qu'on aimerait aussi c'est une
possibilité d'avoir dix journées par an
de
financements pour faire une formation
continue en tant que généraliste hockey
à toute une partie forme assure que si
qu'important parle aussi des difficultés
des médecins pour s'installer des jeunes
médecins à des difficultés des déserts
médicaux qui s'installe même dans les
zones urbaines aujourd'hui quelles
seraient les solutions aussi qui
pourrait être apportée est ce que votre
syndicat un regard là-dessus pour aider
à l'implantation des jeunes médecins et
limiter ses déserts médicaux ce qu'il
faudrait déjà en fait c'est revaloriser
le statut de du généraliste en tant que
tel parce que ce qui fait peur en fait
aux jeunes médecins qui s'installent
c'est là évidemment la charge de travail
surtout dans les déserts médicaux due
notamment à la lourdeur administrative
c'est pour ça qu'on propose aussi d une
dotation financière pour avoir des
auxiliaires médicaux je me soulagerait
d'une partie de la charge administrative
et puis et puis la désertification fait
que de moins en moins de médecins donc
de plus en plus de travail et donc du
coup si on l'a aussi moins de
valorisation par rapport aux salaires
c'est simon compétitif après il ya des
avancées qui peuvent être faites par
rapport aux maisons santé qui sont très
intéressantes et puis notamment le
recrutement des internes pour faire des
stages dans les zones démédicalisé qui
leur donnerait un un pied dans l'ancrage
et puis ensuite une envie d'aller
s'installer dans ces zones là pour
revenir à la mobilisation du jour
notamment de ses médecins généralistes
qui ont fermé leur cabinet pour une
grande partie d'entre tous les syndicats
n'étaient pas forcément d'accord la
fédération des médecins de france qui
représente aussi une partie de la
profession et n'appelait pas à la même
mobilisation aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya
eu une unité malgré tout des médecins
aujourd'hui alors sur certains points on
se
on se rallie à certains syndicats
notamment syndicat des internes licini
avec qui on va voir une mobilisation
commune le 15 mars prochain pour une
manifestation à paris et puis en fait il
ya certains syndicats qui partagent pas
les mêmes revendications
et puis et puis les mêmes modalités de
manifestation de gens apprécient la
diffision ça va forcément être un moyen
pour le gouvernement d'appuyer sur ses
divisions et ses tensions est ce que ça
ne va pas être plus difficile de se
faire entendre par exemple c'est pas
notre art que vous avez c'est possible
après il faut quand même s'harmoniser au
maximum et puis des groupes de travail
qui seront mis en place qui peuvent
permettre de faire entendre la voix de
chacun après moi je trouve que une
diversification des points de vue c'est
aussi riche et intéressant parce que
finalement on a un autre idée mais on
n'a pas forcément le savoir absolu et
donc d'avoir plusieurs expériences de
110 cas différent puis en plus nous on
est un jeune syndicat mais avec des
syndicats de médecins plus mûr ça peut
avoir une vision plus large donc marche
ou pas que ce soit forcément un
désavantage au contraire une
complémentarité et pour conclure la
mobilisation va se poursuivre parce que
cette action aujourd'hui vous l'avait
déjà évoqué le 15 mars dans la capitale
il y aura aussi en forme voilà une 15
mars une mobilisation à paris une
manifestation commune avec eux plusieurs
syndicats notamment les signes et des
internés puis le syndicat des des chefs
de clinique et assistants des hôpitaux
pour continuer à faire entendre notre
voix merci bernadette et en bons du
syndicat national des jeunes médecins
généralistes merci à vous les médecins
qui sont donc en grève aujourd'hui
toujours en lutte ont lavé vous l'avez
entendu notamment contre le tiers payant
généralisé ou encore afin d'obtenir une
revalorisation du tarif de la
consultation va rester dans le domaine
de la santé encore pour la suite de ce
journal le centre médical albert
schweitzer dans le centre ville de
trappes va fermer au mois de juin la
ville en lien avec l'agencé régionale de
santé ars vient de lancer le recrutement
de deux médecins généralistes un local
est mis à disposition des futurs
praticiens les explications de 4x de
l'atome et de patrick jacques de dixmude
fin juin ce centre médical bien connue
des trappistes du centre-ville va fermer
un centre ouvert depuis de nombreuses
années les praticiens ont vendu leur
local on ne peut pas parler à trappes de
désormais 10 jan quand même parce que on
a un autre centre communal de santé on à
l'hôpital on a aussi tous les autres
médecins le problème de fond c'est dans
ce secteur urbain on va définir comme
jours et ce gars ça fait un vide
important à vide important dans ce
secteur qu'il faut donc comblé la ville
en partenariat avec la faculté de
médecine de saint quentin en yvelines l
agence régionale de santé lance un
recrutement de médecins les locaux de
l'ancienne pmi anne-frank peuvent être
mis à disposition de 150 m² avec une
entrée directe sur l'avenue paul
vaillant couturier placé en plein centre
précise le maire transformé pour
l'occasion en vrp on est en train de
monter finalement un recrutement de deux
ou trois médecins généralistes on espère
aujourd'hui j'ai eu une nouvelle
positive mais qui n'est pas définitif
donc voila mail en tout cas les
démarches commença à bien s'enregistrer
j'espère que dans d'ici le 1er ou
juin juillet on aura trouvé deux messins
et comme d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de
plaisir et qu'on qu'on aidera
à démarrer un aider à démarrer cela
passe notamment par la possibilité de
négocier le loyer un centre médical qui
ferme le centre municipal de santé qui
lui va déménager actuellement situé au
square guy forget il va s'implanter dans
le quartier des merisiers dans un local
neuf avec du matériel renouvelé onze
médecins et qui travaillent là qui sont
qui sont en relation dans un réseau les
travaux se terminent le centre devrait
ouvrir le 26 mars en raison du
déménagement le centre yves farge lui
sera fermé du 19 au 25 mars
et pour terminer cette séquence dédiée à
la santé dans ce journal je vous propose
d'écouter notre question du jour comment
relancer la vocation des médecins pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux voici
vos réponses il faut très bien quoi on a
amélioré les conditions de 2,2 de vie
leurs conditions d'exercice et tous et
ce tous c'est pas si facile que ce sera
via des à s'installer et puis des eaux
éviter tout ce qui se passe actuellement
quoi ils veulent supprimer la médecine
libérale causes et aux nouvelles
fonctionnalités tout ça c'est pour ça
qu'ils veulent plus haut niveau à
l'hôpital et ils vont nulle part
ailleurs mais je pense que six ans
installé à plusieurs
mois déjà ils sont pas seuls et ils
peuvent parler entre eux et puis pour
les gares pour les astreintes mais que
les mairies donne un coup de pouce mais
il faudrait peut-être qu'ils aillent
plus son stage justement auprès des
généralistes peut-être qu'il faudrait
qu'il y ait des anciens médecins qui
leur parle de leur filer un petit coup
de main les prennent sous leur aile
c'est à l'école qu'on devrait déjà
encouragé les jeunes les jeunes à entrer
dans cette profession
l'étude annuelle du ufc que choisir
vient d'être publié pendant deux
semaines de fin septembre à début
octobre l'année dernière l'association a
enquêté sur les prix et non plus de 3800
magasins de france dans chacun d'entre
80 produits ont été relevées comparer
résultats dans les yvelines celle
enseigne leclerc à bois d'arcy qui a la
palme du magasin le moins cher avec un
panier moyen et de 351 euros contre 377
au niveau national plus de précision
avec le président de l'union de
versailles écoutez c'est en 2014 par un
pro 2013 à une baisse de 0 7% donc
l'ensemble des produits a diminué et
notamment les produits laitiers ce que
l'on constate quand même c'est qu'il y
ait des écarts les écarts sont très
faibles entre entre les enseignes et
donc aussi là où il ya des géré au
casino il ya un net progrès et même dans
certains endroits ces îles sont avant il
se classe avant leclerc mais je dis bien
les géant casino prend les enseignes
casino et pour connaître le classement
précis des enseignes près de chez vous
en êtes vous sur le site internet de
l'association vous y trouverez une carte
interactive consultable gratuitement
bien sûr mardi matin la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
dans les yvelines organiser une grande
conférence pour évoquer le futur des
commerces yvelinois au coeur de cette
rencontre l'évolution et les tendances
du commerce mais aussi la réglementation
sur l'urbanisme commercial florane
parfait elodie -
avec 6000 boutiques et deux des trois
plus grands centres commerciaux d'île de
france le secteur du commerce tire une
place importante dans les yvelines
pourtant depuis la crise les modes de
consommation ont changé en france la
fréquentation a baissé de 10% dans les
magasins les clients délaissent les
commerces de proximité et les centres
commerciaux pour les enseignes
installées en périphérie sur les 262
commune yvelinoise seuls 110 compte plus
de dix commerces nous on a voulu surtout
alerter les collectivités parce que
certaines n'étaient absolument pas ne se
rendait pas compte c'est quand on
s'aperçoit qu'à des friches commerciales
qui apparaissent de plus en plus c'est
là où les collectivités le maire font
appel à la chambre bien qu est ce qui se
passe lorsqu'un coeur de ville commence
aussi à des périls il y en a de plus en
plus objectif faire un état des lieux et
les évolutions sont nombreuses parmi
elles un fort développement des parcs
d'activités commerciales de plus de 5000
m² et des centres outlet trois centres
commerciaux de ce type ont vu le jour
dans le département depuis 2009
du côté de l'alimentaire les
supermarchés se développe aussi mais
seulement dans des communes de 4000 à
6000 habitants redensifier les
centres-villes et pourtant une priorité
mais la difficulté liée aux réforme de
l'urbanisme commercial freine nombre de
communes et empêchent parfois cette
dynamique il faut être très prudent dans
la bonne cohérence de tout ce qu'on
écrit dans un document d'urbanisme et
l'absence de contradiction entre les
dispositions sont des documents très
lourd à écrire très volumineux et c'est
un travail vraiment d'orfèvre qu'il faut
faire en la matière l'évolution des
règles et de la législation de
l'implantation des commerces des données
importantes pour les élus locaux venus
nombreux à cette conférence
la chambre de commerce cherche avant
tout à leur donner une vision d'ensemble
du territoire l'élu local ni va
essentiellement regarder sa ville et son
périmètre et ils ne voient pas tout ce
qu'il ya autour et tous les projets donc
il va construire son projet pour sa
ville et ses habitants par contre il
tout se passe aussi autour de lui et ça
il n'en a pas forcément la vision
doivent avoir une vision panoramique de
ce qu'il ya sur le département est
relativement important au niveau de des
yvelines pour permettre justement une
croissance et un maintien de toutes les
offres de commerce possible sur le
territoire un enjeu de taille pour les
communes et le département en 2012 le
commerce représenté 17 8% des emplois
salariés dont les îles il
c'est la fin de ce journal je retrouve
demain pour un point complet sur
l'actualité l'essentiel de la semaine
bien sûr comme chaque vendredi
excellente soirée dans un instant filets
qu avec floriane parfait